introduction okay thanks for
introduction and thanks for coming and I
hope that everyone is staying safe and
yeah the tide of this presentation is
optimal product just encryption from
pairings and lwe and this is a swab
thought this is this talk is based on
the work that will appear at Europe to
2020 and this is a joint work with
shredder global from IIT IIT Madras in
India and I'm sure their mother from
heist in Japan so I first explained our
results in short in a work we
constructed the optimal product as the
encryption from tell EE and pairings and
what is optimal for the just encryption
we say that so we say that the broadcast
the encryption satisfies optimal
parameter size if the size of the master
public key cipher text and secret key is
independent from the number of users in
the system or equivalently if the size
is independent it is only probably
already meeting the number of users in
the system here we denote the number of
users by Capital m and our construction
is the first optimal broadcast
encryption without motolinia naps or
indistinguishability of a station as for
the security we prove our construction
Institute under the
l.w assumption in the Parana general
model more generally we in fact in our
paper we construct more general thing
namely we constructed cpab
or ciphertext policy attribute based
encryption with some special specific
efficiency properties that implies
optimal prodigious encryption as for the
efficiency properties that we require I
will explain it later in this talk and
what is product as the encryption
impro teaches the encryption you have
many users in the system and a sender
can encrypt a message for a set of users
in the system for example let us
consider
a situation where a sender wants to
encrypt a message for leftmost three
users in the system in this picture and
to do so a sender can encrypt a message
to obtain a single ciphertext and this
ciphertext can be decrypted by any users
in the intended receiver set for example
this user can decrypt the ciphertext to
retrieve the message using her secret
key and these users can decrypt the
ciphertext to retrieve the messages as
well because they are in the intended
main user use a set however this user
can't decrypt the ciphertext because
this user is not in the intended
receiver set and we require that even if
you collude with other user who is not
allowed to decrypt the ciphertext it is
still impossible to recover the message
or even it is impossible to infer any
information of the message being
encrypted so this then this property is
called collision resistance and we
require this property by default and
there is a trivial solution for product
as the encryption the idea is to prepare
public key for each user by playing
public key encryption and then we
encrypt the message by each public key
one by by using the secret key as a
result the size of the ciphertext will
be linear in the number of users in the
recipient set this can be as large a
sort of of n where n is the number of
all users in the not sorry so L n is the
number of all users in the system so the
question here in the broader just the
encryption is whether we can achieve
shorter cipher texts or not sorry how
should I think of the set of users being
specified should it like it's just
literally a list or is it like a list of
attributes or yeah I think so you can
consider the set of users
indices 1 2 3 up - it's just a list like
nothing nothing specified by the user
identity or not arbitrary identity in
this case so the integer from 1 to n ok
yeah so thanks for the question so and
the next time I'm going to explain
previous works on broadcast encryption
the trivial solution
I explained satisfy some parameters like
this he at the size of the master public
key and cipher text will be as large as
the number of views all users in the
system whereas the secret key is
constant and as for the ingredient it
only requires plain public key
encryption the first construction that
is fruitfully collision resistant and
and with short ciphertext is proposed by
Pony Gentry who and waters and they
construct these parameters in particular
the size of the ciphertext and the
security is very very very short however
the problem of the constructions that
they need very long master public key
which is linear in the number of all the
users in the system and their
construction is constructed on party
nyan ops and in the same paper they also
consider some other variant of the
construction where the problem of having
long master public key is mitigated at
the cost of longer ciphertext and the
problem of having optimal broadcast
encryption had been long open standard
open problem and the first solution was
given by pony Chantry and waters who
constructed the optimum product as the
encryption in our sins from not eating
enough they are not any generic Treaty
of the
not even an update require is log n
where n is the number of users and in
our case we remove the necessity of
motolinia not and we obtain optimal for
the cast encryption from fighting a map
and l w assumption here we ignore Polly
polynomial factor in the security
parameter in this table in particular
this means that polynomial in log
function of n is also ignored and also a
unit that we discount earlier
constructions in this table that do not
provide for the collision resistance and
short ciphertext and actually there are
many more works on this subject but I
only listed some of them here and next I
am going to explain attribute based
encryption or a B II short because this
is in our work we actually constructed a
B E and then convert it into product as
the encryption what is that attribute
based encryption in attribute based
encryption you can generated generated
master public key on the master secret
key and using the masters public key you
can encrypt a message for some attribute
X using the master secret key you can
generate a secret key for attribute Y
and the decryption is possible if x and
y satisfy some relation let us denote
the relation by our if our of X y equals
to 1 you can retrieve the message
however if our of X y equals to 0
the decryption is not possible and I
require similar notion of collision
resistance for a b e
namely if you collude with other users
who are not allowed to pick up the
ciphertext
it is still impossible to recover the
message or even just the information for
the message being encrypted
and by specifying the relation R we can
consider various types of a a be in cpab
or a cipher text attribute based
encryption the cipher text is associated
with some socket that specifies the
policy as to regarding who can decrypt
the cipher text and the secret key is
associated with some string the relation
is defined as a he valuation evaluation
result of the socket or name to the
string Y and you can consider your
notion of cpab e that we call k PB e or
key policy maybe here the ciphertext is
associated with some string whereas
secret key is with such circuits and by
restricting thus restricting the class
of circuits you can consider a de for
mc1 sockets where the depth of the
circuits is bounded by some logarithmic
function in the security parameter you
can cost a CPA B and KP b4m seven
circuits next I explain that prodigious
the encryption is captured as a special
case of CPA be4 ends even circuits to do
so in order to generate a secret key for
user index J you just generate a secret
key for CPA be for the same index chain
and to encrypt a message for the set of
users s in product just encryption you
first generator function f sub s like
this here F sub s is the set of
recipients and F sub s takes us input to
index J and how to put one word zero
depending on the depending on whether J
is in the set or not you can
easily see that this encoding cpab skin
with this encoding satisfies the
functionality of broadcast encryption if
the user is not in the set it is not
possible to decrypt the cipher text and
if you you if the user is in the set it
is possible to decrypt the cipher text
and this function f sub s will be
implemented by the specific circuit that
I explained in the following the psychic
F sub s takes as input user index J in
the binary form and then compare the
index with all indices in the set in
parallel it compares whether it equals
to the index or not then finally we take
B or in the circuit to see if the output
is 0 or 1 you can easily see that this
circuit indeed implements the
functionality of F sub s that we want if
J is not in the set they are to put it's
0 and if J is in the set they are to put
is 1 and this circuit satisfies some
nice properties this circuit if sub s
has shot input because the input string
is only of order of log n because this
takes as input a binary string of user
index as an input and this circuit has a
shadow depth namely depth with order of
log n because this compares to input
string with all indices in the set in
parallel
due to the parallel computation just
depth of the circuit is very shallow
these are nice properties of this
circuit but this circuit has wide width
because because of the parallel
computation the width of the circuit is
order of n where is the number of all
users in the system so this this circuit
has a shot to input shallow depth but
has wide width and the observation here
is that CPA with widget independent
compact parameters is in fact enough for
optimal order just the encryption what
is emitted independent compact
parameters now we say that the cpld
scheme has width independent compact
parameters if the size of the master
public key cipher text and of Sikhi is
independent from the width of the
circuits supported by the scheme the
efficiency of the CPB efficiency of the
cpab scheme can depend on the input
length input length and depth of the
circuits supported by the scheme because
they are on the logarithmic in the
number of users however the size
shouldn't depend on the width of the
circuits so from now on the goal of this
talk is to construct cpab e
with rigid independent compact
parameters and unfortunately every
existing cpab scheme doesn't satisfy
with an independent efficiency with
independent compact parameters however
we have something close to our goal in
the attribute based encryption scheme by
pony and other authors bg+
does satisfy with independent efficiency
however the construction is CP is KP a
be year rather than CPI be recorded CBB
is what we want let us check the
efficiency of EC plus let us consider a
circuit class that consists of the
circuits whose input length is L depth
is d and width is W and master public
key of BG + construction is polynomial
in the input length and depth and the
security parameter so the
is independent from the width of the
circuits and the size of the ciphertext
is similar this doesn't depend on the
width of the circuits and secretiy can
be even shorter because this doesn't
depend on the input length of the
circuits so because bgt plus satisfies
something similar to what we want the
our approach to have the CPI be a scheme
with with independent efficiency it's to
convert this is post que pide into cpab
while keeping the efficiency somehow and
because the task is just to convert the
KPD into cpab
maybe one can consider a simple ideas
however here I explained that there the
as far as I can tell simple ideas don't
work the first idea I can come up with
to convert KPD into CPA de is to just
simply swap the ciphertext on the secret
key namely when you want to generate the
secret key you encrypt the ciphertext
and when you want to generate a
ciphertext
you generate a secret key in fact this
allows us to swap the ciphertext and
attribute ciphertext and the secret key
attributes but this doesn't work first
secret key can be generated publicly
publicly in the resulting scheme because
the encryption algorithm is public in
vg+
another serious problem is that in the
resulting scheme the secret key will be
associated with some message whereas the
syntax of the curve of the a b e wants
us to associate a message with a
ciphertext rather than the secret key so
what we want is to move the message from
the south from the secret key to the
cipher text but as far as I can tell
this is not trivial to achieve
so this doesn't work another standard
idea to convert kpb e into CPI B is to
use the universal circuit MD when you
encrypt a message for some circuit F in
the contraction you regard this circuit
description as a string and then encrypt
a message for this string using the KPA
B and to generate a secret key for
attribute X you first consider a circuit
use of X and then generate a secret key
for this circuit use of X and the use of
X is the universal circuit which is
hardwired with the value of x which
takes us input that is a description of
circuit F and outputs f of X and indeed
this allows us to have the CPB scheme
but without the efficiency property that
we want the reasons that input the
length of the use of X is dependent on
the size of the circuit EF and this
permit the size of the bg+ parameters is
dependent on the input length of the
circuit supported by the skin so in the
end you will have the construction whose
parameter size is dependent on the
description size of F which is not what
we want so this doesn't work and so we
want something more sophisticated
sophisticated to have cpab
and so we use the come in order to
achieve this we use the compressibility
of TCG plus what is the composability of
each process we say that be cheaper we
say that an encryption algorithm of
zebras satisfies the cantos ability if
the encryption algorithm can be divided
into the following two steps
in the first step we generate the set of
encodings since the by be for all i from
1 to L and B which is 0 or 1 and here L
is the length of X the input to the
circuit and we require that this step
can be done without knowing the
attribute X you can consider this as a
of 9/10 of the encryption algorithm
where you don't use you don't know the
attribute X for which you encrypt a
message and in the second step to
generate the cipher text for attribute X
you choose some specific subset of the
ciphertext and codings
namely for example if the attribute if
the first bit of X which is the
attribute for which we encrypt we choose
C sub 1 0 and if you if they it--but of
x equals to 1 you choose C sub i1 and so
on
namely we output C sub I X I for all I
and this constitute a valid bg+ cipher
text for attribute X and because this
constitutes valid cipher tips for
attribute X this cipher text can be they
could decrypt it by using VG + secret
key for attribute F with F of x equals
to 1 so this is the property that we
call the composability and our first
attempt is to combine the work by
cle-cle and say hi and visit was a B
scheme in the assistant construction the
authors constructed functional
encryption from public key encryption
and cobble circuit
here we replace the carbon circuit with
digital plus a big construction to do so
in order to generate a master public key
we prepare two L public keys of playing
public key encryption you will have a
key Jessup ID for all positions of a and
B as a master public key and the master
secret key consists for corresponding
secret keys and to encrypt a message for
for the socket F in the CPA PE you first
to generate BG t plus a master public
key master secret key by yourself and
then you also generate a secret key for
function f using the BG g plus master
secret key and we put P to the
postmaster public key and a secret key
in the cipher text
furthermore you generate the cipher text
and coatings of eg plus by using the
offline phase of the encryption
algorithm then we have C sub R B for all
positions of a and B finally we encrypt
each of them using the corresponding
positions of the cipher text namely he
know that encrypt the encrypt sis of IB
we will use P case of ID the cipher text
consists of the encrypted version of
cipher text encoding of BG plus BC plus
secret key for function f and master
public you under secret key for
attribute X consists of secret key of
the plain public key encryption scheme
is case by X I for all I all positions
of Y and to decrypt the cipher text
you first decrypt the ciphertext
encoding of top of corresponding
position to that secret key to recover C
sub I X I for all positions of I namely
the secret key chooses to out of and so
one out of two cipher texts of the
cipher text column and this this C sub I
X I for all I constantly fall in
psychotics for attribute X in visit was
using which it was secret key one can
decrypt the ciphertext to reduce the
message so this is the construction and
let us check the efficiency of the
scheme
let us consider a circuit class that
consists of circuit using length is L
depth is d and width is W and we see
that this construction in fact satisfies
with independent compact parameters that
we want the master public key of the
construction consists of two L public
keys of trained public key encryption
scheme clearly the size of the master
public key is independent from the width
of the circuits supported by the scheme
so the size of the master public key is
okay and as for the cipher text as for
the ciphertext the cipher text consists
of a encrypted versions of the cipher
text encoding of widget + master public
key and this is + secret key for
function f by the by the with
independent efficiency of the underlined
digit + construction the size of the
master public key and secret key and
encodings are independent from the from
the width of the circuits and this horse
even if these encodings are encrypted by
the plain public key encryption scheme
so the size of the cipher text is also
okay
and the secret key of the construction
consists of L secret keys of plain
public key encryption so the size of the
secret key is also independent from the
width of the Sacketts supported by the
skin so size of the secret key is also
okay
in fact this construction satisfies the
efficiency property that we require and
this construction is also single key
secure which can be proven in a similar
manner to the work by a sister however
the construction is not collision
resistant collision of justice collision
of only to users break the security for
example let us consider collision of two
users whose I would use an index is zero
zero zero and one
the secret key corresponding to the
attribute to its secret key is
corresponding to the lower Rowlf the
master public key secret key
corresponding to a sorry so upper up
role of the master public key and the
secret key corresponding to the
attribute one alone will be secret is
corresponding to the dual role of the
master public key namely by just
clearing two secret keys you can reveal
you can know the entire secret key is
corresponding to the master public key
and namely you can recover the master
secret key of the construction by you by
just two key queries so this breaks the
security
and and the main challenge here is to
add a collision resistance for the
construction our approach for adding
collision resistance in very high level
is to use the power of pairing groups
because because we are going to use
pairing groups there is a question so
the question is where does the
description of satisfaction because I
mister mister question so I'm not sure
whether for which page this question is
for you please write page page for which
this question before so yeah yeah so in
the at least I can say that in the
context of attribute based encryption
attempt 1 so in the in our first attempt
construction in our first attempt to
construction in fact state s is not
really found here because we are
considering cpab construction so here
the ciphertext is associated with some
function f and the key is for attribute
X and what we explained before is that
by specifying the function and by
specifying the function f and string X
you can obtain broadcast encryption
scheme and in this encoding thus active
is specified by the user set s
so here it is not really fun to consider
set s because we are just constructing
cpab scheme here so I will continue so
and the main difficulty here is to how
to add collision resistance and because
I'm going to use the pairing sharing
groups I introduce some notation the
pairing groups consist of Group G 1 G 2
and G T and these groups Egypt with map
II this map takes us into the g1 to the
a G to the B and output of G 1 G 2 to
the AP and we use we will use bracket
notation and we will denote G 1 to the a
by a in bracket sub 1 G to the B will be
denoted by B in the bracket of bracket
sub 2 and we will use the notation to
the GT to the C and for group element in
G 1 I will use red color box and group
element in G 2 will be with yellow box
GT maybe to the box and so let me see
the Christians so I think people are
just having a discussion in chat okay
okay thanks so yeah yeah so so let me
explain our approach for adding
collision resistance in our first
attempt the reason why our first attempt
failed is that the Decrypter recovers C
sub I X I in the clear
so just combining the two partial
decryption results
I see the passion partial decryption
results means C sub I X I for some IX
you can recover hold C sub I be namely
you can you can combine the partial
decryption result to recover hold the
encoding of PC plus so this was the
reason why this doesn't work the first
step to use pairing groups is to lift
them on the exponent what happens if the
Decrypter learns them only on the
exponent namely C sub I X I for all I
and this doesn't still work because
collision of two users still jump obtain
C sub I B for all I and B and this
breaks the scheme because using C sub IV
for all positions of Ryan B you can read
you can recover C sub I X I for any X of
your choice this is problematic and
approach to add collision resistance
into two to prevent this kind of attack
is to prevent the adversary from
combining the partial decryption results
because the because the attacks I
explained use it because the attack I
explained is based on the combination of
the partial decryption results of
different users so our idea to prevent
this is to change the scheme so that the
Decrypter recovers randomized version of
the cipher text encodings of pg+
namely they decrypt a will recover Delta
times C sub I X I on the exponent where
Delta is user specific randomness and
consider a situation where two users try
to clear them and they use index by J
and K so the partial decryption results
that the adversary will use us to
collude can recover his Delta J times
ciphertext and codings
and Delta K times ciphertext and codings
here Delta J Delta K are different
because they are users with specific
randomness and because they are
randomized by the user specific
randomness intuitively there is no
meaningful way to combine them this is
our intuition and our approach to our
collision resistance however however as
I explained in the following this until
some difficulties so there are two
challenges with this approach the first
step first challenge is about the
correctness because the bgt process our
text is on the exponent and even
randomized by the user specific
randomness the question is how is it is
still possible to decrypt - decrypt is
it possible to decrypt the ciphertext
because they are even they are on the
exponent in particular the group we use
is DL hot groups where discrete
logarithmic problem is hard so this is
not a trivial one and the other
challenge is about the security if the
Decrypter
adversary only learns this component
that J times some Delta J times C
English VDC plus n codings
the construction may indeed be secure
this in fact requires the security proof
but
but we at least have to show that the
adversary only learns these components
the 30 times
this is Plus encoding on the exponent
how do we how do we make sure that the
other party does not obtain any other
information than these components this
is the second challenge and I first
explained how to resolve the first
challenge before doing so let us record
the decryption algorithm of pg+
in the first step of pg+ in the first
step of decryption algorithm pg+ we
first compute a linear functionals of S
sub F depending on the value of Master
public key attribute X and secret key s
K sub F and this function satisfies the
following property if if we apply the
linear function on the ciphertext the
cipher text encoding you will recover
message plus some noise here to Nova 2
here is Q denotes the underlined bg+
modulus and in the second step of the
decryption algorithm we remove the noise
by seeing this value message plus noise
is closer to to Nova 2 or 0 if it is
closer to 2 over 2 you recover a message
you reek of a message 1 and it is closer
to 0 the message is 0 so and we have to
perform this algorithm on the exponent
luckily the first part of the algorithm
can be implemented on the group on the
exponent because region computing a
function on the exponent and we can
apply that in your function even if
these these components are randomized by
the
uses specific randomness if we apply
them in a function on the exponent then
you will have randomized version of the
message plus some noise so the first
step can be performed on the exponent
but how about a second second
step in the second step we have to
remove the noise to recover the message
however this is not straightforward
because the message passed noise is
randomized spiders use a specific random
is Delta and this Delta is exponentially
large so the encoded value on the
exponent is exponentially large how do
we manage this this is Ho take I just
make sure I understand correctly the
outer buoy modulus q is the same as the
order of the bilinear group
ya-ya-ya-ya-ya true
thanks for the question yes that's a
very important point we said modulus of
E Plus to be the same as say must
underline bilinear group so that yeah
this is V not do you does the Decrypter
also somehow get Delta in the target
group by itself yeah so this is what I
want to say in the next one yeah yeah
thanks
yeah so yeah how to resolve this problem
the idea is very simple actually we just
did the decrypted on Delta on the
exponent as well yeah so this is the
first step for for resolving the problem
of correctness and the second step is to
is is based on the following observation
if noise is polynomially bounded one can
the message by brute force search namely
we can just check all possible message 0
1 & noise noise value
so the decryption is possible if message
if the if the message is zero or one and
notice in the polynomial it compound it
the thing we have to change how to have
polynomially bounded nodes in order to
do so we use the careful information
algorithm of Broca's can vikon tonton
and openness and vinegar naughty a day
gave latest iteration algorithm for
insulin circuits where the noise of the
internals of the resulting encoding is
polynomially bounded we use the
epilation algorithm and as a result our
construction will be limited to the our
construction only handle and c1 circuits
but this circuit cpab skin forms one
circuit with the efficiency it's in fact
sufficient for broadcasting encryption
as i mentioned in the previous slide so
we can resolve the first challenge by
this by the by these ideas next I'm
going to explain the second change the
second challenge was about the security
we wanted that to decrypt a run only
these components and nothing else
and this allows us to prove the security
while keeping the correctness how do we
realize that the question is how do we
set ciphertext and the secret key so
that we saw that the combination then
only reveals the intended components and
nothing else and the naive idea to set
this instance at the ciphertext to be
the set of n codings
of each is brass on the exponent of
g-ronn and muster publicly on the secret
key of PG pass and we also said secret e
to be dealt on the exponent of G sub 2
and G sub T in fact this encoding allows
us to recover the recover Delta sub C
Delta times C sub I X I on the exponent
of GT under Delta to the T on the
exponent Delta on the exponent of GT and
the former term can be recovered by
taking pairing product between the on
the exponent of 2 and the corresponding
position of the cipher text encoding on
the exponent so this allows us to have
correctness but this doesn't provide the
security in fact we can recover their
the time SI sawai be for all position of
I and B by comparing product between
Delta on the exponent of G 2 and
corresponding position of the cipher
text encoding and if we have Delta x is
of IB on the exponent for all I and B
you can recover the randomized version
of the bth cipher text for any attribute
X which is problematic the lesson
learned from this failure is that the
secret key should be tied to the
attribute X here you can see that the
secret key is not tied to the attribute
X in any way another idea for predicting
adversary from doing some unintended
computation we introduce position wise
randomness so that pairing product
between only matching positions of the
ciphertext and the secret key yields in
useful terms for the adversary food for
decrypter
the master puppeteer of our construction
consists of position-wise randomness on
the exponent of GE 1 namely we generate
random w sub IV for all positions of
that of a and B and then lift them on
the exponent of G sub 1 the ciphertext
and in order to generate the cipher text
regenerate the BG g plus encoding since
a by B for all positions of a and B and
then give them on the exponent by using
the corresponding positions of the
position wise randomness you will have W
sub I B times C sub IV on the exponent
of G 1 and the secret key consists of
Delta divided by W sub I X I for all
position Y and the Delta on the exponent
of of T sub D and to decrypt of
ciphertext we take a matching position
of the secret key encoding and the
cipher text encoding for example we
retake pairing product between Delta
divided by W L Phi X I with WI
X I times C sub I X I here at the
picture represents the case of X I chose
to 0 and as a result you can recover the
other times C sub I X I on the exponent
of GT for all I this allows you to the
group decrypt the ciphertext and I say
you can see the position wise randomness
cancels each other in this pairing
product computation because the pairing
product on computation is is regarding
the in the regarding the matching
position of the cipher text encoding and
the secret key encoding
so quickness is okay how about the
security what if the adversary takes
pairing product between imagine
positioning of the ciphertext component
and the secret key component if the
adversary take how much in position of
the peering product you will have
something you will have that time
something like this here the position
was randomness doesn't cancel each other
because they're different monomial
namely the resulting term that is
obtained by taking matching position of
the ciphertext and the secret key and
codings is randomized divided by by
something and due to this part the
obtained turn is useless in the
subsequent computation intuition here is
that if the adversary does not follow
the correct part of the computation then
the adversity convict yet use this
information namely the only user 14 for
the adversary to do is to take parent
product between matching position of the
ciphertext and the secret key to recover
their the time speed is it was encoding
for attribute X on the exponent this is
the intuition next I provide an provide
an the description of the final scheme
to generate master public key and master
secret key we generate position wise
randomness W sub ID for all positions of
I on P and then we list them on the
exponent of G sub y to encrypt a message
for attribute for the circuit F we first
run which is positive algorithm to have
to generate to be digitized master
poverty and master secret key and then
using the master
Kirti you generator security for
functionals and we also run the first
part of bt+
encryption algorithm to obtain SI sawai
be for all position of ion be recoded
this step can be done without knowing
the attribute X which is associated with
a secret key and the final output of the
ciphertext consists of randomized
version of the [ __ ] plus encoding on
the exponent which is it was must assist
master public key and secret key for
function f and the key generation
algorithm of the construction first
generates a random image Delta which is
user specific and then output down the
exponent of G sub T Delta divided by W
sub I X I for all position of time now
I'm going to explain how the decryption
algorithm works it first pass the cipher
tips like this and then we recover
theater x which is the prostatic stem
cody by taking maxim position of the
cipher text encoding and the secret key
encoding for all I namely me recover
Delta times C sub I X I for all I 10 we
compute the linear functionals of Earth
from B to G parameters we then apply
this linear function on these randomized
version of BG + n coatings on the
exponent as a result you will have
theater timeless message plus noise on
the exponent we can recover the message
by brute force
brute-force search over all message and
noise here the noise is polynomially
bounded because we implicitly use the
careful evaluation algorithm for m7
sockets this is the description of final
scheme and let us check the efficiency
of the construction in fact the
efficiency of the of this construction
is asymptotically the same as as our
first attempt here
we just recently replace the public key
encryption with group elements so the
optimal parameter size is preserved by
just because we just replaced the public
encryption with copayments next I'm
going to explain the security proof for
construction because the security proof
is done on the polynesian group model i
briefly explain the intuition compiled
in a general model the intuition about
linear general model is that the only
things that an adversary can do with
group elements is to take pairings then
take linear combinations and see if it
equals to 0 if it doesn't equal to 0 the
adversary learns nothing about the
encoded value even if it is equal to 0
the adversary learns nothing else the
adversary only guards the fact that the
evolution result is 0 and nothing else
to give the security proof first we
observe what information can be
adversaries see you know if you don't
have the lwe arrow if you take the bgg
ciphertext without the arrow yeah and
then encrypt then put it in the exponent
and so what do exactly what you did that
isn't that isn't secure or or is it is
it not I think it is not secure because
if there is no no error on the if there
is no error then in the decryption you
can take any answer so if if there is no
error then you can have any any linear
combination works for the decryption so
the problem is that the value recovered
here will be not with the noise I'm so
sorry so so so in order for the
decryption to work if there is noise you
need the linear function in sub F should
should not grow the size of the noise
too much right yeah noise you can take
arbitrary linear combination to recover
the value so we need error
thanks for the question and yeah so so
because go into the details of the
security proof the turning size the
adversary can see the challenge
ciphertext Chanin cipher text consists
of these components in the randomized
version of the ciphertext and codings
and the BTC plus most a public key and a
secret key and the other buzzer can see
many secret keys
the other words I can see is case of x2
2 J where J is user index and we require
that if f of X J should be 0 the
decryption is not possible and these
secret keys will be with some user
specific randomness what the adversary
can do is to take the first step that
the advice I can do is to take pairing
products between the ciphertext
components and secret key components as
a result the adversary can see these
terms here this term is obtained as a
parent product between a matching
position of the ciphertext and the
secret key components here the position
wise randomness doesn't cancel each
other and this kind of time is obtained
by taking parent product between the
matching position of the ciphertext and
the secret key here the opposition was
randomness chances each other a next
step that the adviser can do is to take
linear combination
among these components let us name the
set of set of elements that is obtained
by taking and matching positions of the
ciphertext and security component by a
and P is the set of component obtained
by taking not simple taking parent
products of much in positions of the
ciphertext and the secret key encoding
and the thing that the adversary can do
is detecting a combination among the
terms from a on the be given the BT t +
security + BG + master public key our
first claim is that if the adversary put
a turn from a into the linear
combination the result is not
zero with overwhelming probability this
intuitively says that it is useless to
put a ton from a into the linear
combination because the computational
the result of the computation is anyway
not zero the adversary cannot obtain
information and this allows us to
concentrate on the linear combination
among terms from B this intuitively
means that what this reflects our idea
of taking and matching position of the
taking parent product between the omits
in position the ciphertext and a secret
key is useless now I'm going to explain
the intuition for the claim one
intuition for the proof of the claim one
hear the term of this this kind of term
the jwi be divided by double i prime b
prime for different i be an electron be
a try i prime and B prime appears only
when take in pairing product between
this specific cipher text encoding and
this specific secretiy encoding namely
system each time in a only appears once
in the set since in other words these
terms are multiplied by different
monomials and different monomials cannot
cancel each other in the binding a group
model by a linear combination this means
that this this implies the claim this is
the intuition for the security proofs
different monomials cannot cancel each
other and every monomial in the set a is
different and this ingestion can be made
rigorous using Schwartz tubulin
thanks to the quick question also a
question there is a Christian quick
question since this is a p PK scheme we
don't need a J in Delta J sorry I I
don't understand the question that is
party yeah
J is for user for each user so what was
j j is the query index for the key query
made by the alpha sorry the first the
first query will be with index J equals
to 1 the second query is with J with J
which is equal to 2 and so on okay so
let us continue and yeah thanks to the
first first claim we can say that it is
useless to put the hood up to to turn
from a into the linear combination so we
can concentrate on the linear
combination of mountains from B the
second claim we made is that if the
adversary puts ton from B with different
Delta J into the combination namely if
we combine we try to combine Delta G and
Delta K with different indices j k then
the result is not zero with over an
improbability this record each Delta J
is user specific randomness so and B is
the partial decryption result that is
obtained by trying to declare ciphertext
using the secret key so this in
particular intuitively means that there
it is useless to combine partial
decryption results by different users
because they are randomized by different
user specific randomness
this reflects the idea idea of avoid
collision collision attack the intuition
photos for the trophy is very simple
different monomials cannot cancel each
other but in a combination each terms
times from B with different Delta G and
Delta K are clearly randomized by
different monomial Delta G and Delta K
so except for Ricky it is not possible
to cancel each other by owning a
combination this is the intention and
this this claim in chickadee says that
it is useless for the Alpha Sri to
combine partial decryption result by
different users and missing in
particular this means that collusion is
not useful for the other party to attack
the scheme so here region which I erase
the index J because we can assume that
the other person only makes single
secret key secret key query and what we
have to prove is that this distribution
doesn't relate the information of the
message being encrypted in fact from the
single key on the single ciphertext
security of pieces pass we have that the
bg+ secret key master bounty and the
ciphertext in is indistinguishable from
secret key master poverty and randoms
drink in particular this means that the
ciphertext doesn't reveal any
information of the message and this
implies that this this in distinguished
bt holds even if we we lift the
ciphertext and codings on the exponent
this means that this distribution
doesn't reveal the information of the
message that is encrypted so as desired
this distribution doesn't reveal the
information of the message so this I
conclude with security proof this
provides some intuition and next I am
going to so having done with the
security proof and the construction I'm
going to compare our construction with
with work by bra Christiana Park in
downtown that is posted on the ePrint
ARCIC very recently even though the
paper was posted very recently they
construct their work predates two hours
and we have some intersection in the
first step both our welcome the
construction construct
cpab with with independent efficiency
and then convert it into optimal
prodigious the encryption and the works
the verge regarding how to add collision
resistance in our case we introduced
pairing up earrings to prevent collision
resistant to prevent collision attacks
whereas EB 20 introduced of a variant of
ib e / attribute based encryption from
lattices to add collision resistance as
for the final final result our
construction is perfectly secure in the
general group model so of course this is
a heuristic security model but we can
provide an security proof rigorous
security proof in this model
on the downside our construction will be
broken by a quantum computer because we
use pairings crucially in our
construction in addition our
construction can only handle turns even
sockets on the other hand will be 20 the
construction will be 20 doesn't have any
security proof however their
construction may be contemplate secure
because they do not use any condom me
insecure primitives and furthermore the
construction can handle tiny sockets not
limited to n Sigma sockets so next I
provide some summary we constructed the
cpab for n even sockets with widget
independent compact parameters from
lattices in piling a general Cooper
model and this implies the first Optima
prodigious the encryption without
motolinia Maps or indistinguishable
investigation in the paper we actually
showed that the cpab scheme implies
identity based broadcast encryption with
similar efficiency properties and
finally I'm going to list some open
problems the first open problem is to
have Optima brother just encryption from
standard assumptions hope free from
decision aldini assumption and a double
assumption more ambitious Cole would be
radagast encryption solely from lattices
I remarked that this is very interesting
even we don't consider opthamologist
optimal parameter sites broadcast
encryption from awwe
with shorter ciphertext size 10 order of
M is long-standing interesting open
problem
other open problem would be to construct
a CPA with widget independent compact to
permit us for all circuits actually BB
20k a candidate for such a construction
which is very interesting but we want a
construction with security proof
another open problem or direction would
be to find out vacation of our technique
for other problems so thank thank you
for listening this is the end of the
talk
I guess if people have questions they
can yeah so sure I have a question maybe
to begin with yes have you for instance
probably would have considered other so
the about the third open problem the one
third possibility action application of
this technique to other problems so
really rely on this user dependent
randomness I mean one possible idea
could be can these techniques mix in it
to say valid witness until she oh yeah
really this one won't be extendable is
just because the user dependent
randomness can't mean over here you like
that each time you give a secret key you
can fix a see this randomness component
and tie all the secretly components
together in something like witness
inspection you have to give out a
universal secret key that works for all
possible inputs actually I tried with
miss encryption we tried I'm just
wondering if you have any thoughts on
what I mean how difficult is the problem
even given these techniques how far do
you think the barrier is the obvious the
obvious construction that one could
think of that won't work just because
the proof no longer works because of
these user dependent randomness issues
the immediate problem that this doesn't
give witness encryption is that we
cannot provide the secret key yeah
because we have we have to provide
secret key for the position of that
and public kids depending on the value
of the attribute yeah so I feel that
this kind of technique applicable for
some variant of attribute based
encryption or something that has that
has set up algorithm where you have
master secrets consider trying to sort
of bootstrap this construction just put
I mean this is just between our random
idea just trying to just see if you can
just have this computation of the
circuit the the policy circuit outside
of the outside of the exponent and just
do a final decryption sort of like a
which is up in the exponent produce I
mean I think we didn't consider serious
need of the application of the kind of
randomized encoding but maybe the
problem is related to the fact that we
cannot put drop attribute based
encryption for hands you want to all
circuits for example we don't have
attributed based encryption for circuits
whose modular sites is polynomially
bounded
maybe yeah we didn't seriously looked
look into the application of encoding
randomized encodings so maybe this is
related to the problem I mention yeah
thanks for questions yeah I guess there
is a question is not dynamic due to the
usage of bg+ status cannot support more
than n users without updating the public
parameters so no I think that if I
understand the question correctly the
answer is no name the reach and generate
any number of secret keys in the cpab
scheme let us record that usage of PC
plus is on the sly in the encryption
algorithm the BG power plus parameter is
generated during the encryption
algorithm and it is not it is not
related to the master public key or
other parameters does this answer that
question at least I think the question
is no we don't have any bound on the
number of user number of users in the
system in a construction thanks
I guess if there are no other questions
yeah you can just virtually tank shut
again I'm sure oh okay miss I found that
there is a Christian is it for
is it possible to formulate a standard
model assumption and which the skin or a
slight modification it's secured in the
standard model for example it says
something about it are the examples in
the exponent yeah I think it would be
possible and we are working on this as
far as I can tell
construction from standard assumptions
is very difficult and maybe this is very
interesting if possible so just to
follow up on that the one year at you
mention that you're working on is it are
you getting able to relax ggm to like a
interactive assumption I don't know
whether I can say sorry yeah yeah but at
least because I said that in the
standard model we remove that Jenny
Cooper model entirely in the standard
assumption sorry in the standard model
okay yeah thanks for the question so
thank you [ __ ] again I'll probably end
the recording now yeah